(ambient music)
- I've always just tried to push myself
to see the world and explore.
Eventually, I found myself
really concerned about
the fact that I was spending
my time in the outdoors
without doing anything
beneficial for the world.
I started Adventure Scientists
believing that there would be
thousands of people like
me who love the outdoors
and wish there was ways they
could make a difference.
(light acoustic guitar music)
We are a non-profit
organization based in Montana
that mobilizes thousands of people
to go out and collect scientific data
for scientists who are using it to solve
massive societal issues.
If you can imagine thousands of people
who are out hiking and skiing
and biking and climbing
around the world
collecting scientific data
that has been requested by scientists
that will help them solve problems,
that's what we do at Adventure Scientists.
(ambient music)
We've got about 8,000 people
a month coming to our website
asking how they can get involved
and we built this network by giving people
in the outdoor community a way that
they could make a
difference with their time.
We've collected the largest data set
on earth for micro plastics.
We sent out volunteers
all around the world
to over 100 different countries
to collect scat samples.
We send these scats back
to the lab at Harvard,
and this brilliant
research team has been able
to narrow the search for
the genes responsible
for antibiotic resistance
down to less than 90 genes.
(ambient music)
We've just hiked our way into
the Lolo National Forest.
This is right on the edge
of Western redcedar's range,
and so this is a super
exciting tree for us
to core and get some genetics out of.
(light acoustic music)
We're getting samples because
as the climate changes
and adapts these trees that
are right on the fringes
of the habitat are likely to have genetics
that could really help us
mitigate climate change
and the effects of climate
change on these tree species.
And then the other
reason is because we want
to create methods for the
U.S. Fish and Wildlife Service
to determine exactly where
any piece of wood came from
and whether it was legally
or illegally harvested.
(light acoustic music)
When we are choosing projects,
the most important to us
is that there's gonna
be a tangible pathway
from data collection to
something being different
in the world.
(ambient music)
(skis scraping against snow)
The outdoors, for me, makes me feel
like there's some normalcy
in a very chaotic world.
(ambient music)
To take my son out here and
getting to hike with him
and show him this incredible
place, it's amazing.
It just means the world to me to be able
to expose him to this
part that I love so much.
This is a gift and a
privilege to have this now,
and I'm not sure this
will be here forever.
We need to empower scientists
with every single tool
available on the planet
to make them successful,
because our entire world and our
entire livelihood depends on it.
(ambient music)